to what do I owe the pleasure you old
sandbagging son of a [ __ ] are you doing
oh my god 50 stitches he's gonna look
like a Bond villain shut up hey guys hey
you're very good yeah it's nice thank
you
it'll grow out
I don't care what you're laughing at
stop trying to give it a skew no sorry
guys I'm in a rush right nut what hey
get to the back of the line man
all right look buddy I got a meeting in
three minutes all right we all have the
same meeting get to the back sorry
traffic we were getting coffee there's
ruin really well but she's in text me
for three days
well maybe she's been busy she's not
into you man you got a move on
do you think you two will have the
project done by tomorrow absolutely not
no no hey Devon do I get my facebook in
May yeah you coming no not a chance
we're going to round bar kind of like I
picked me up for Garrett bars awful it's
so expensive to the long line
go to wavy dance better atmosphere all
by around you know garrison waist
what's your drink frozen margarita yeah
I'm gonna get you an old-fashioned